TERRORISTS.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
TONIGHT EXAMINE CONCERNS BY SOME
OF THE RIGHT ABOUT THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT.
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS WAS
APPOINTED BY A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT BUT SOME CONSERVATIVES
ARE NOW WORRIED HE MAY BE
DRIFTING PERMANENTLY TO THE LEFT
TO BALANCE THE COURT.
JUST LAST WEEK, HE SIDED WITH
THE COURT'S LIBERAL WING AND A
PAIR OF CASES, INCLUDING THE
DEATH PENALTY APPEAL, SOMETHING
THAT IS OCCURRING WITH GREATER
FREQUENCY.
TONIGHT FOX NEWS CHIEF LEGAL
CORRESPONDENT AND ANCHOR OF
FOX NEWS THAT NIGHT
SHANNON BREAM TAKES A LOOK AT
THE ROBERTS RECORD.
>> SOME DAYS ARE BETTER THAN
OTHERS.
>> CHIEF JUSTICE OF THE
UNITED STATES, FIRST AMONG
EQUALS, CAUGHT ON THE POLITICAL
SPOTLIGHT HE SAID ASSIDUOUSLY
TRY TO AVOID.
ON A RANGE OF HOT BUTTON ISSUES,
JOHN ROBERTS IN RECENT WEEKS TO
SIDED WITH HIS FOUR MORE LIBERAL
COLLEAGUES, INCLUDING A FEBRUARY
VOTE TO BLOCK ENFORCEMENT OF A
RESTRICTIVE LOUISIANA LAW ON
ABORTION CLINIC ACCESS.
LAST WEEK HE RULED FOR A DEATH
ROW INMATE OVER HIS
RIGHT-LEANING CALLINGS
OBJECTIONS.
IT'S THE LATEST SIGN THE
64-YEAR-OLD ROBERTS IS HITTING
THE PAUSE BUTTON ON THE
CONSERVATIVE FULL-COURT PRESS
ISSUED INVITE PRESIDENT TRUMP
AFTER NOMINATING JUSTICES
NEIL GORSUCH AND BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
>> INCREMENTALIST MINIMALIST
STRATEGY.
WHATEVER YOU ARE HOPING FOR OR
FEARING IN YOUR PREFERRED AREA
OF LAW, THIS COURT IS NOT GOING
TO MOVE WITH GIANT STEPS.
>> SINCE NOVEMBER, THE VOTES
HAVE PROVED DECISIVE HALF A
DOZEN TIMES.
ISSUES LIKE IMMIGRATION ASYLUM
AND TRANSGENDERS IN THE
MILITARY.
WHILE THESE VOTES DO NOT YET GO
TO THE MERITS OF THE LARGER
ISSUES, THEY SIGNAL ROBERTS'
SHAKY PLACE IN THE COURTS METAL
AS THE SO-CALLED SWING JUSTICE,
UNOFFICIAL TITLE HE INHERITED
FOR NOW WHEN ANTHONY
KENNEDY RETIRED.
THE CHIEF HAS NOT EXPLAINED WHY
HE HAS TAKEN A CAUTIOUS GO SLOW
APPROACH, LEAVING THE CURRENT
DOCKET FREE OF HIGH-PROFILE
DISPUTES, INCLUDING DACA,
INDIANA ABORTION RESTRICTIONS
AND LGBT WORKPLACE
DETERMINATION.
PEOPLE SAY IT MIGHT BE A PATTERN
OF STRATEGIC AVOIDANCE.
HE HAS TALKED ABOUT KEEPING THE
JUDICIARY OF PARTISAN SNIPING.
>> PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW WE ARE
NOT DOING POLITICS.
THE NEED TO KNOW WE ARE DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT, THAT WE ARE
APPLYING THE LAW.
>> THE CHIEF JUSTICE'S
RELATIONSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOT BEEN
WITHOUT FRICTION.
THE TWO ENGAGED IN A PUBLIC SPAT
LAST NOVEMBER AFTER THE
PRESIDENT CRITICIZED HIS
IMMIGRATION RULING MADE BY WHAT
HE CALLED ON OBAMA JUDGE.
IN A STATEMENT, ROBERTS STRONGLY